what's the biggest thing I should maybe
be concerned about as an American
citizen going back to Trump's Twitter he
tweeted on februari 17th the fake news
media failing New York Times NBC News
ABC CBS CNN is not my enemy it is the
enemy of the American people is he not
an American person I mean this is
concerning because it kind of seems like
it's maybe contradicting the First
Amendment of the Constitution a little
bit that's the first one it's the number
one it's the best iment it's the number
one top amendment right so but basically
that one is protecting like freedom of
speech freedom of the press you know and
he's not taking away any of their
freedoms but he's kind of like placing
this distrust and like sort of
discrediting here's my biggest concern
right now and this might be selfish I'm
a media person and he certainly didn't
call out BuzzFeed in this instance yes
before but is Trump potentially telling
the American people that I'm their enemy
no because if I'm their enemy I want
more stuff I want a layer I want a
badass car I want space weapons I want
expensive lying all the time that I
could be like constantly doing this I
want better stop if I'm gonna be an
enemy enemies have a cool stuff that's
true can we call haze I think we should
check back in with haze and see what he
thinks boom boom hey guys jeez we're
talking about the tweet the Trump sent
saying that all the news outlets were an
enemy of the American people I want to
know since I technically work for a
media company that has a new tablet hey
if I am then an enemy to the people and
be if you aren't even bigger enemy of
the people and see what does this mean
no first of all far as i can tell being
in the state's the transitive property
so it's like a six degrees of separation
thing if you know someone who's an enemy
of the american people and are like
relatively close ties with them it
passes on to you like a cold
oh that's just my working theory so
you're a bigger enemy than me but I am
still an enemy yes correct because you
work for this failing pile of garbage as
well well I aspire to your position sir
in all seriousness it's really terrible
and scared yeah so today at CPAC Trump
had a speech where he tried to say no no
I was talking just talk about fake news
and journalists who make up sources
which happens to be everyone in my mind
the fact that he's trying to say that
anyone who disagrees with him is
automatically a liar and fake is a way
to sort of burrow away at the idea of a
free press in a way that she would
expect to see in less free country than
the United States of America charged
again at CPAC said something on lanza I
don't mind bad stories when I've earned
them except he seems to never believe
that he's truly earned them and goes
back to our good friend Vladimir Putin
in similarities when you see how the
Russian state controls most of the media
you're very few independent outlets left
who else in history and you can name all
of them has made an enemy of the press
to the people they represent oh you know
some dudes named Benito a doll Uncle Joe
just some some friendly characters Bobby
you got a down in Zimbabwe as a person
who technically a cornea Trump is an
enemy would you ever go on record saying
something like Trump is kind of like
Hitler mmm no suit [ __ ] soon for that
okay I'm trying to having read so anyway
okay this is a potential first step in
the wrong direction wrong direction will
agree with that I've been lead reading a
lovely hit their biography and there are
some things from like I see I see yikes
but we're not quite there yet well I
appreciate your time and since I aspire
to be a bigger villain I'm not really a
reporter so I do think Trump is probably
very Hitler like but you don't have to
say that and I'm not technically new
signing off I don't know if Trump is
actually Hitler I don't know if Trump is
actually Putin you know he's going to be
his own kind of person right no one can
be Hitler Hitler Hitler no one can be
Keith hammers burger I'm teeth avarice
burger that's just the facts right those
are both fact see we're not Hitler Trump
is not Hitler Trump is not keen Trump is
not Keith you are not Trump these are
true things I'm making everybody who's
like an authority that's very worried
right now those of us who like facts and
truth we're really concerned we don't
want to make too many crazy claims we're
really nervous right now it's scary to
make crazy claims but right now Trump
has made it scary to make factual claims
or seems like he's trying to make people
not believe like accurate reporting he's
turning us against ourselves kind of
like Holly your games come on like
Hunger Games yeah oh my God we're gay I
was gonna go for Hitler but actually
it's way more like oh no it's it's
pretty Hunger Games Eve I'm safe with
hunger game yeah that's fiction I can't
i just say that he's Hitler why can't i
just say like I just want to know why I
can't just very clean once I'm the enemy
no one's gonna believe me anyway